BUT WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE TWO OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE IN TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW ONE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO BE HERE ATTENDING A FAMILY
FUNERAL. SO WE'RE HOPING WE
WILL GET A QUORUM BUT UNTIL
THAT POINT. ARE WE WILL PROCEED
AS A SUB COMMITTEE I WANT TO
WELCOME EVERYONE BACK HAPPY NEW
YEAR. I HOPE IT'S GOING TO BE
GOOD ONE AND WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS BUT TO. A
WE'LL KEEP OUR FINGERS CROSSED
THAT THIS A GOOD HEALTHY YEAR
FOR EVERYONE SO. I WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE WILL NOT BE HEARING.
FILE ITEM ONE SB TO A ONE. OF
THE WINTER BILL TODAY IT DID
NOT PASS THROUGH ITS COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY- SO THAT IT DOES IS
NOT BEFORE US TODAY- WE DO
HAVE- FOR ITEMS HOWEVER- WE
WILL START WITH FILE ITEM THREE
SB FIVE TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR.
ARE HERTZBERG AND- I THINK THIS
IS A BILL THAT- IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD SO PLEASE.
SENATOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO STAR
WE OF THIS COMMITTEE OF
PROVIDES A TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH THEN WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION IF THERE IS ANY TO
WITNESSES. THE TWO MINUTES EACH
AND WE DO ALLOW A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN AND THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT TO COME UP AFTER OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO GIVE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
THEN AFTER THE OPPOSITION
SPEAKS WE DO REQUEST IF YOU
WANT TO. INDICATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THAT YOU
STEP FORWARD AS- OVER AT THEM
THE MICROPHONE OVER THERE AND
GIVE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
AND INDICATE OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
OPPOSITION BUT THE WE DON'T
ALLOW ANY ADDITIONAL SPEECHES
AT THAT POINT AND WE OPEN IT UP
TO THE- OUR DIETS FOR QUESTIONS
AT WHICH POINT HOPEFULLY IF
THERE'S NEED FOR OR DESIRE FOR.
A ROBUST DISCUSSION WE WILL
HAVE IT AND THEN WILL VOTE ON
THE ITEM AS SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO WE NEED
ONE MORE PERSON TO GET THEIR
CORN BUT WE DO THE VICE CHAIR
HERE. CONSIDER BRIDGES COME
CENTER GONZALEZ THE ON. AND THE
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU ADAM- CHEER
THIS MEASURE IS INSPIRED BY OUR
ESTEEMED SECRETARY OF STATE TO
SEE BEING TO SAVE TIME IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY IN THE IMPORTANT
OPERATIONS OF HIS SENATE OTHERS
THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE NOT JUST DEALING
WITH ELECTIONS BUT HE ALSO
DEALS WITH BUSINESS ENTITIES
AND NAME IS OUR VACATION AND
ARE WILLING- DIFFERENT BUSINESS
TO DIS WHETHER THEY'RE LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES LIMITED
LIABILITY PARTNERSHIPS OR
CORPORATE ENTITIES OR SUB.
AFTER US AND THE REALITY IS
SURPRISED THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THIS BEFORE BUT THERE'S VERY IS
DIFFERENT STANDARDS BY WHICH
THE OFFICE HAS TO LOOK WHEN
THEY DETERMINE WHETHER THEY
ACCEPTED NAMEOF A CO CORPORATE
OR L. L. C. AND THE LIKE. AND
SO AS A RESULT OF THE INGENIOUS
FOLKS IN THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO STREAMLINE SAVE COSTS
MAKE CUSTOMERS THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE EASIER IN SO THAT WHEN I
SEE TO AN TO. INCORPORATE
HANNAH BETH JACKSON
INCORPORATED AND SHE HAS SPENT
ABOUT ACTION LLC. SHE CAN MORE
EASILY THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CAN AVOID THOSE KINDS OF
DECEPTIONS AND UNDERSTAND HOW
TO REGULATE THE DIFFERENCE
AMONG THE VARIOUS ENTITIES AND
WITH THAT WE'VE GOT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE WAS
A SPONSOR THIS MEASURE HERE
TODAY TO. FURTHER FOR ME. THANK
YOU SIR HERTZBERG- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHURCH ACCIDENT
MEMBERS HAD MALL HAUSER ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY OF STATE-
EXPEDIA. SENATOR PRETTY IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB FIVE
TWENTY TWO WHICH WILL HELP MAKE
IT EASIER TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. BY ADOPTING A
DISTINGUISHABLE IN THE RECORD
STANDARD REPORT FOR APPROVING
NEW CORPORATION NAMES. SB FIVE
TWENTY TWO WILL REDUCE THE TIME
THAT IT TAKES TO COMPARE
PROPOSED CORPORATE NAMES
AGAINST EXISTING NAMES. OF
AUTOMATION AND OTHER
ANTICIPATED EFFICIENCIES WILL
ALLOW THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE. TO ADD STAFF RESOURCES
TO OTHER KEY BUSINESS PROGRAM
AREAS AND IMPROVE CUSTOMER
SERVICE. WE THANK THE COMMITTEE
OF STAKEHOLDERS FOR SUGGESTING
CLARIFYING TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
WHICH WILL BE TAKEN BANKING
COMMITTEE. AND BERKELEY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS ITEM. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS OTHER ANY QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT TO ARE JUST ONE
QUESTION- THE STATE'S GOING TO
REDUCE THE TIME NECESSARY TO
KIND OF CALL THROUGH THIS CAN
YOU TO- HOW IS THAT GOING TO BE
ACHIEVED. WELL THE- THIS
PROCESS AS USE IN OTHER STATES
AND IS ALREADY USED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR LLC'S AND OTHER
PARTNERSHIPS- WOULD RESULT IN
UNIFORMITY ENTER AND THEREFORE
THE STANDARDIZATION OF THE U.
PROCESS ACROSS THESE THREE A
PRIMARY- CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
TYPES CORPORATIONS LLC IS AN L.
P.'S. SERVER AYE SOS THIS THING
WISH UPON THE RIGHT STANDARD
WILL REDUCE COST SAVINGS BY
ROUTE REDUCING STAFF FOR YOUR
TIME AND INSTITUTING DEFINABLE
STANDARDS THAT CAN MOSTLY BE
AUTOMATED A LOT OF WHAT WE DO
RIGHT NOW WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE. BUT IT WILL BE ABLE THE
AUTO SO THERE WILL BE- A
QUICKER REVIEW PROCESS YEAH
THIS WILL ALLOW WHO- BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA TO SECURE A WIDER
VARIETY OF NAMES IN MY-
ALLOWABLE UNDER A LOT TOO SO
FOR THE CORPORATIONS THEMSELVES
THEY'LL HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITY.
AND CURRENTLY YOU NEED TO IT
THIS NEEDS TO BE DONE
LEGISLATIVELY IS AT THE POINT
THAT'S CORRECT YEAH THERE'S A
THERE THERE ARE TWO STANDARDS
THAT ARE DEFINED IN STATUTE
THE- THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE.
CARRIED OUT THIS WAY BUT WE
WANT TO WE NEED TO. CREATE THE
POSITION IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE- GO TO
SENATOR MONNING WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
PLEASE ESTABLISH CORN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. JACKSON HERE FOR
JUST. A JACKSON HERE BORDERS
HERE TO RUSSELL GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HERE JONES JONES HERE
MORNING MORNING HERE STERN
UMBERG BY CASKEY. RIGHT A
QUORUM IS PRESENT OF CENTER
MONNING FLOOR SHARES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I'M SORRY I
MISSED THE EARLIER
PRESENTATIONS I MAY HAVE MISSED
THIS BUT I THINK IUNDERSTAND
THE PURPOSE OF THE LEGISLATION
BUT HOW DO YOU RECONCILE IF
THERE'S EXISTING CONFLICTS
BETWEEN AN EISTING L. L. CENA.
EXISTING CORPORATION. SAID A
FAIR QUESTION TO SET THEY'RE
ALREADY INCORPORATED THE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD IS MAKING THIS
MORE EFFICIENT GOING FORWARD TO
AVOID THESE CHALLENGES OF IF WE
HAVE A THE CONFERENCE ALREADY
BEEN RESOLVED THE JUST THE IN A
LESS EFFICINT MANNER- AS A
RESULT OF WHO'S ALREADY BEEN
INCORPORATED- HASN'T LCN LP
THIS JUST MAKES THE PROCESS
GIVES YOU. THE FACTORY
AUTHORITY GO FOR TO MAKE IT
BETTER. AT IT SO IT'S
PERSPECTIVE PERSPECTIVE. THERE
COULD STILL BE AN EXISTING.
SHARED NAME IDENTITY THAT WOULD.
RIGHT GRANDFATHERED IN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
HERTZBERG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ACTUALLY ASTRONOMICAL
RANGE OF. MOTION BY SENATOR
BORCHERS THE MOTION IS TO PASS-
TO BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS NEXT NEXT THE STOP
SO WITHOUT A PLEASE CALL THE
MEMBERS. JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
BORDERS. OR DECIDE TO RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D JONES
JONES I'M MONNING MONEY AYE
STERN I'M BURKE. NUMBER AYE WHY
KELSEY. ALL RIGHT THAT HAS THE
SEVEN VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO AND-
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLE IT'S SIX TO
ZERO RIGHT WE'RE MISSING TO
MEMBERS SIX TO ZERO WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OPTION
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR. AND
IT NEXT STOP. OF LET'S GO WITH
SENATOR UMBERG. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO SB. FOUR FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU OF MADAM CHAIR IN
MEMBERS. LET ME BEGIN BY
THANKING STAFF FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTION I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- IN
PARTICULAR THAT THE RESEARCH BE
CONDUCTING MANNER CONSISTENT
WITH THE ASILOMAR PRINCIPLES AS
A STAFF KNOWS I'VE BEEN A LONG
PROPONENT HERE IT TOO SO MORE
PRINCIPLES SINCE LAST FRIDAY-
SO LONG TIME IN THE A. I. WORLD
A LONG TERM YES MANAGER- THERE
WE GO. SO SB FOR WOULD ALLOW
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA-IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW TO WORK
WITH THE RESPECTIVE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURTS IN PARTICULAR
ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
TO- DEVELOP ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE STRATEGIES AND
MECHANISMS IN PARTICULAR TO
ASSIST WITH THOSE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD COUNSEL- THERE ARE
SEVERAL AREAS WHERE THIS WOULD
BE MOST IMPORTANT LET ME JUST
ADDRESS A COUPLE EXAMPLES
BEFORE TURN OVER TO. DOES NOT
TOMORROW. WELL ONE IS WITH
RESPECT TO FOR EXAMPLE
PROTECTIVE ORDERS OR
RESTRAINING ORDERS CONCERNING
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- IDEALLY THE
SITUATION WOULD BE. THAT WHEN
SOMEONE. FILLS OUT A PETITION
APPLICATION FOR PROTECTIVE
ORDER THAT THEY FILL IT OUT IN
ITS COMPLETE. OFTENTIMES THE
THERE ARE ITEMS THAT ARE
MISSING SO FOR EXAMPLE- DETAILS
OF THE EVENT THAT LED THAT-
PERSON TO APPLY FOR SUCH AN
ORDER- IT IT IF THERE ARE
DETAILS THAT ARE MISSING OR
EVEN SUCH A SIMPLE THING IS A
DATE MISSING- IDEALLY YOU YOU
GET KICKED. BACK AND SO THAT BY
THE TIME THE APPLICATION GOT TO
THE BENCH OFFICER BENCH OFFICE
OF COURSE WOULD MAKE THE
DECISION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS ORDER WOULD BE GRANTED- AT
LEAST THE REQUISITE INFORMATION
WOULD BE PRESENT- RATHER THAN
FOR EXAMPLE SUBMITTING IT
VENTURE. HAVE A BENCH OFFICERS
I'M SORRY. THIS IS A COMPLETE
YOU'LL HAVE TO COME BACK THE
FOLLOWING DAY OR EVEN LATER ON
THAT'S ONE AREA OTHER IS WITH
RESPECT TO EXPAND- WE HAVE
DECIDED THAT THAT CERTAIN-
INDIVIDUAL SHOULD HAVE THE
RECORDS EXPUNGED. ON FOR
EXAMPLE THE LENGTH OF TIME
BETWEEN CONVICTION AND- A
CERTAIN OTHER PEER TO TIME AND
THAT ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
COULD IDENTIFY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO SHOULD HAVE THE
RECORD EXPUNGED. WELL WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS THE PRESIDING
JUDGE THE ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE NOT CAMARA
IS OUR WITNESS JUDGE. AFTERNOON
YOUR HONOR WELCOME AND TO LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR- COMMENTS THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME. UP IT'S MY PLEASURE TO OF.
SUPPORT THIS BILL WHICH WOULD.
ALLOW YOUR CHARACTER COURT TO
PARTNER WITH VARIOUS YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OR TWO
ADVANCED. ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE APPLIED TO LAW IN
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS AS WELL
AS- EDUCATE AND- A MAKE SURE
THAT. OUR LAW STUDENTS IN OUR
UC SYSTEM AT LEAST UC IRVINE-
ARE FAMILIAR WITH A AYE AND
CAN. OF ACTUALLY A APPLYING A
AYE TO THE SITUATION THAT WILL
ASSIST. OPERABILITY GETS AND
THOSE WHO. OTHERWISE COULD NOT
THE AFFORDED HURRIES IN
ADDITION. A AYE. IS BEING USED.
IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES AT OUR
COURT AND WE ARE EXPLORING THAT
THE ORDERS CHARACTER COURT IS
ONE OF THE MOST ADVANCED COURTS
WITH RESPECT TO TECHNOLOGY WE
HAVE. CERTAIN CONNECTION WITH
RESPECT TO PRIVATE. INDUSTRY
GOOGLE AT THE FOR EXAMPLE AND
MICROSOFT THAT THE OTHER COURTS
DON'T HAVE ENTERED THE
CONNECTIONS. OF WE HAVE BEEN
GRANTED A CERTAIN DURANT'S
TECHNOLOGY GRANTS WITH
DIRECTORS JUST A COUNCIL
INITIATIVES. IN EXCESS OF A
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH ALLOWS US
TO IT WILL BE AT- TECHNOLOGY IN
WAYS THAT ARE INNOVATIVE AND
CUTTING EDGE FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE. IMPLEMENTED COURT USUAL-PORTAL- AT VARIOUS JUSTICE
CENTERS WHICH ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
USE APPS. TO A TEACHER OR THE
CASES AT VICTOR BUT JUSTICE
CENTERS IN AND HOW TO LOCATE
THEIR CORE ROOMS WE HAVE A- IF
BLIGHTED. CERTAIN OTHER A JUROR
ABSENT WHICH ALLOW PEOPLE WHO
UP ARE GOING TO HAVE A JURY
SERVICE AT A CERTAIN. THE
JUSTICE CENTER TO KNOW WHEN
THEY ARE GOING TO BE SUMMONS-
TO- A CERTAIN COURTROOM IN A TO
PERFORM THEIR JURY SERVICE-
THESE ARE RATHER RUDIMENTARY
BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT. USES APPLICATION
WHAT MAKES OUR COURT MORE
USEFUL FOR USER FRIENDLY AND
ACCESSIBLE THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
THAT WE COULD IMPLEMENT. THE A
I WITH RESPECT TO OUR COURT
PROCESSES WITH RESPECT TO- AS
THE CENTER INDICATED EXPUNGE
RENTS FOR ONE IT COULD.
EXPEDITE THAT PROCESS. WITH
RESPECT TO FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE ABOLITION OF THE
FELONY MURDER RULE. OF THEM BY
VIEWING CERTAIN EXTENSIVE.
CRIMINAL FILES THEY CONSIST. OF
GREATLY AND EXPEDITING A JUDGE
IN DETERMINING WHETHER A
DEFENDANT IS. IS ENTITLED TO A
RE SENTENCING BASEDON OF THE
EVOLUTION OF THAT ROLE SO WHAT
THE RESOURCES THAT THE DISTRICT
COURT HOUSES WELL AS THE
RESOURCES OF THE YEARS
CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT TO
PROFESSORS. WHO WERE VERY NOTED
IN THE AYE FIELD- WILL CREATE A
SHIRT SYNERGISTIC SITUATION
WHICH WILL BENEFIT WHILE THE
COURT BUT THE- UNIVERSITY AND
ITS STUDENTS AS WELL. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
WE DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOMEONE IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK PER SE- BUT VERY BRIEFLY
AND THEN WILL JUST SIMPLY TAKE-
NAME AND AFFILIATION. EVEN
BOMBS YOU JUST ALSO OF
CALIFORNIA WITH GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS HEATHER PREDATOR CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS OF THE DíAS
NOT TO VERY GOOD. THANK YOU-
ARE THERE ANY OTHER. WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
REACHING NUMBER TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE DICE I HAVE A
COUPLE THOUGHTS I WANT TO SHARE
WITH ALL OF YOU IN THIS- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE A AYE IN ALL THESE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES OFFER
VERY VERY EXCITING
OPPORTUNITIES- BUT- IF YOU
RECALL FROM JUST ABOUT ANY
SCIENCE FICTION FILM THAT YOU
HAVE SEEN THE MIND IN THE
CAPACITY TO TAKE WHAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE IS FOR GOOD. AND
TRANSPOSASE INTO NOT SO GOOD OR
EVEN EVIL ALSO EXIST SO WE ARE
NOW INTO SORT OF A BRAVE NEW
WORLD TALKING ABOUT IT HERE IN
A WAY THAT I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
TO HELP IMPROVE- PRO PER
LITIGANTS ARE PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME FOLKS WHO HAVE NO ACCESS
TO LEGAL COUNSEL OUR LEGAL AID
AS SOCIETIES IN THIS AND
ASSOCIATIONS ARE MAXED OUT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED SO. THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
AND FOR THE COURT TO ALSO
DEMONSTRATED TO INTEREST IN
TRYING THIS NEW APPROACH- THE
AND AS WE HAD DISCUSSED OUR- A
I HAS TO BE. APPROACH VERY
METHODICALLY A AND THOUGHTFULLY
SO I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR AGREEING. TO USE THE
PARAMETERS AND THE GUIDANCE- IN
THE GUIDELINES OF THE ASILOMAR
PRINCIPLES- AGAIN. BECAUSE WE
ARE- THEN INTO A BRAVE NEW.
WORLD IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE SET THESE KINDS OF
PARAMETERS AS OUR MINIMUM
EXPECTATIONS AND AGAIN IT'S MY
HOPE THAT AS WE- ARE A FURTHER
LOOK AT A AYE WE ADOPT THOSE
ASILOMAR PRINCIPLES TO THAT-
RESEARCH IN THAT EFFORT AS
WELL. BUT THERE'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
LEARNING ABOUT A I AND ALL
THESE ALGORITHMS AND THAT'S THE
NOTION OF IMPLICIT BIAS. WHO'D
A THUNK BUT THERE IT IS AND WE
KNOW THAT IT DOES EXIST THEY
CAN BE BAKED INTO THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND SYSTEMS AND-
THAT'S WHY I THINK CONTINUING
TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE- START
MOVING INTO THAT A OUR WORLD
ARE GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO
LOOK AT THESE THINGS. TO MAKE
SURE WE ADDRESS IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS IMPLICIT BIAS- AGAIN
IT'S IMPORTANT TO. TO HAVE FIND
THESE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS BUT WE
DON'T WANT TO STREAMLINE ACCESS
TO THE COURTS FOR INDIGENT
CALIFORNIANS AT THE EXPENSE OF
POTENTIALLY INADVERTENTLY
FURTHER MARGINALIZING THEM. AND
SO- I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE IN THAT PROCESS I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
DIALOGUING WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IN THE COURTS. TO
ENSURE THAT ANY LEGISLATION-
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION THESE
OTHER CHALLENGES A COUPLE OF
WHICH I'VE MENTIONED THERE'S
ALSO THE CHALLENGE. OF FOR
EXAMPLE ANY PROPRIETARY RIGHTS
IN THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE CREATED
BY THIS HOW WE GONNA DO WITH
THOSE- AND THE SURROUNDING THE
UNAUTHORIZED PRACTICE OF LAW.
WHICH WE HAVE SEEN IN THE FORM
OF AN ATARI OWES HERE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND DO THEM
SEVERE CREDITS OKAY WELL THIS
IS VERY EXCITING. THERE ARE.
OBSTACLES IN ACTION AND IT IS
MY HOPE AND I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE. THIS OFFERING AND
THE COURTS. WILL TAKE ALL IN.
THIS WEEK- FORWARD SO I JUST
WANTED TO BE SURE THAT I FEEL
THAT WAY BUT ALL IN A AYE STUFF
THAT WE'RE DOING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE HAS GREAT
POSSIBILITIES. AND GREAT
POTENTIAL DOWNSIDE SO THOSE ARE
MY THOUGHTS AND IF ANYONE ELSE
HAS A COMMENT SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU TO. I WILL WORK AND-
SENATOR UMBERG FOR OF REMOVING
THIS FOR- I THINK THIS WOULD BE
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
FURTHER IN THROUGH THE A AYE-
SUBCOMMITTEE. BUT I THINK WHEN
YOU COMPARE WHAT WE ARE DOING
IS AMERICANS TO WHAT OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE DOING AROUND THE
WORLD. WE ARE. WE ARE NOT
PROGRESSING FAST ENOUGH AND I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP. WITH A I AM THIRTIES TO
BEING. IT'S ALL THE- DATA ENTRY
IT'S A BASELINE ACCUMULATION OF
INFORMATION THAT ALLOWS FOR
PERSPECTIVE USE. AND WE HAVE TO
START SOMEWHERE AND I THINK
THAT IS PROBABLY WHERE. YOUR
PILOT PROGRAMS GOING- I DO KIND
ONE ECHO- ONE CONCERN- THAT THE
CHAIR WOMAN WHO IDENTIFIED IS
THAT. I HOPE THIS DOES NOT GO
IN THE DIRECTION OF. PREDICTIVE
OUR DECISION MAKING BY THE
JUDGE AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE WHETHER WE START LOOKING
AT. AT THE PAST SENTENCING
PATTERNS YOU'RE LOOKING A
PROPENSITY FOR RECIDIVISM ALL
ALL THAT WOULD BEAR INTO A
JUDGE'S DECISION MAKING
PROCESS- I'M I SINCERELY HOPE
THAT WE DON'T ALLOW IT TO-
MOVING THAT INTO THAT RANGE
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT FROM THE
OTHER SIDE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. SIDE SO WE
START TALKING ABOUT AUTUMN
REESER TALKING ABOUT
NOTIFICATIONS THAT CAN BE GIVEN
FOR WITNESSES OR FOR PEOPLE TO
ATTEND COURT- THAT'S OF THOSE
ARE SIMPLE PATTERNS THAT CAN BE
THAT THAT CAN BE PUT IN I THINK
IF WE DO IT AND WE'RE LOOKING
UPON IT IN THAT FASHION. I
THINK THIS IS A FANTASTIC. I AM
I AM UNHAPPY THAT YOU DID NOT
FRESNO IN YOUR PILOT. AREA BUT
MAYBE NEXT TIME. THE DISCUSSION
OF BUT I THINK IF WE CAN SEE IT
WORKING WELL I THINK WE'VE GOT
TO IT'S SO ORANGE COUNTY AND IS
IT ALSO. ALAMEDA COUNTY THROUGH
A- BUT IF THIS DOES WORK AND I
EXPECT THAT WE'LL START SEEING
IT MOVE BEYOND THAT. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS BECAUSE THE
COURTS HAVE INDICATED A STRONG
INTEREST AND THAT THESE LAW
SCHOOLS HAVE ALSO INTERESTS.
INDICATED A STRONG INTEREST-
BUT AGAIN I THINK WE NEED TO
START SOMEWHERE BUT WE NEED TO
BE CAUTIOUS WE ARE NOT CHINA-
WE DON'T WANT THIS INFORMATION.
OF BEING USED IN WAYS THAT
MIGHT TONIGHT DEMOCRACY AND THE
ABILITY PEOPLE TO EXERCISE
THEIR FREEDOMS. WHICH ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO US IN THIS COUNTRY
SO I THINK THIS IS A GOOD. A
GOOD STEP IN PERHAPS IT WILL
EXPAND GOING FORWARD. STERN YOU
HAD TO OF THOUGHT YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SORRY
MISS THE OPENING HEARING TO AND
THANKS TO THE STAFF OVER THE
BREAK FOR WORKING HARD WE KNOW
IT'S GONNA BE GREAT YEARS OF.
THANKS FOR THAT. SHARE SOME OF
THE TREPIDATION APPRECIATE
THOUGH THE NARROW SCOPE OF THE
PILE AND FRANKLY THERE'S VERY
FEW INSTITUTIONS I DRESSED. AS
MUCH AS THE ONES YOU'VE NAMED
IN THE PILOT. COMMAND THE- THE
COURT- FOR STEPPING AND ALSO
THE DEANS. I'M A LITTLE BIASED.
BEING FROM BERKELEY BUT I
APPLAUD SHIMMERING SKI FOR
STEPPING IN AND- AND AS FAR AS
HAVING SOME OF THOSE SORT OF.
CONSTITUTIONAL. GUARD RAILS AND
THAT SORT OF BUILT INTO THE DNA
OF THIS PROJECT I THINK YOU'VE
GOT. THE DETENTIONS ALSO
ENGAGED TO HAVE THAT SORT OF
PUBLIC INTEREST IN MIND AND ARE
NOT JUST LOOKING FOR. YOU KNOW
OPTIMIZATIONS OR STREAMLINING
FOR THE SAKE OF STREAMLINING
BUT REALLY TO PURSUE JUSTICE
AND SO IT IF THERE'S AN
APPROPRIATE TIME I LOVE TO BE
ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR THE
MEASURE- AND I WAS HOPING IT
DOES HAVE TO BE NOW COULD. IN
YOUR CLOTHES BUT JUST TO. OUR
STATE A LITTLE EARLY IN THE-
THAT IN SCHOOL COULD LOOK LIKE
JUST. JUST USE A BADGE AND
ASIAN RECOGNIZING THAT THINGS
ARE GONNA HAVE TO CATCH UP WHAT
DOES THAT EXPERIENCE LOOK LIKE.
FOR THE- FOUR HUNDRED IF WE
HAVE THIS DISTRICTS ARE
ASTONISHING WITH THAT. JUSTICE
ISSUES BUT FOR HE 80% OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE MAKING
LESS THAN THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH USING SELF HELP
PROGRAMS WITH EXPERIENCE START
TO LOOK LIKE POTENTIALLY IN
THESE ALAMEDA ERROR OF C. FIVE.
THANK YOU MANAGER. PART I THINK
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION ABOUT
USING THIS PROGRAM FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATIONS FOR
EXPUNGEMENT AND I THINK AS IT
EVOLVES WE'LL FIND OUT
POTENTIALLY MORE THINGS THAT
CAN BE. USED FOR SO I THINK
THAT'S WHY. DOING THIS
GRADUALLY AND VERY
TRANSPARENTLY I THINK IS GOING
TO BE KEY JUST TO BE CLEAR THE
BILL DOESN'T SPECIFY THOSE
INITIAL FOCUS SERIES IT LEAVE
SOME NOTES AGGRESSION BUT THOSE
COULD BE ANTICIPATED OKAY
EXACTLY HOW TO THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ALL RIGHT TO OF
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. UP
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF SOME USEFUL COMMENTS AND AN
INSIGHT LET ME RESPOND A FEW-
FIRST WITH RESPECT TO IMPLICIT
BIAS. THAT THAT IS A CONCERN
ITS CONCERN OF ALL OF OURS OF
IMPLICIT BIAS EXISTS RIGHT NOW
IN THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM. OF THE
DAY BETWEEN IMPORTANT BY THAT
EXISTS RIGHT NOW. I ASSUME USE
ARTIFICIAL SINCE IS THAT THAT
ONE IS MORE A SPIRIT AND GO
BACK IT WILL BE YOUR GOLD MAKE
SURE YOU CAME BACK. THE SYSTEM
LET THEM PUT EGGS STUDENT WHAT
OUTPUT WERE CREATED OF IMPLICIT
BIAS EXISTS SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
SOMEONE- HANDS IN THEIR
PETITION FOR A PROTECTIVE
ORDER. IN A CLERK NOTICES THAT
THERE'S NOT A DATE ON IT I
CLERK AND THEN FOR TO THE BENCH
ALSO BRANCH OFFICES INCOMPLETE
COME BACK TOMORROW OR THE CLERK
CAN SAY. YOU KNOW YOU FORGOT TO
DATE THE END DEPEND UPON WHO
THE CLERK TELLS THEY FOR. THE
MAY REFLECTIVE BOB THIS MAY
REFLECT THE WORK ETHIC OF THE
CLERK MAY REFLECT THEIR
GENEROSITY OF SPIRIT BUT BUT
ALREADY EXIST IMPLICIT BIAS AND
SO PART OF THIS IS ACTUALLY.
NAY IT'S THAT IMPLICIT BIAS.
SECOND IS ON TRACK ALL OF THE.
THE END WITH RESPECT TO THE A
MACHINE MAKING JUDICIAL
DETERMINATIONS THOSE ARE
ANTITHETICAL TO ONE THE PROCESS
AND TO THE VISION OF THIS
PROCESS- WE- ANTICIPATE THAT
THE BILL BE OTHER APPLICATION
SO I CAN THINK OF SEVERAL RIGHT
HERE FROM CIVIL AREA IS THOSE
OF YOU WHO PRACTICE IN CIVIL
LITIGATION A DEMURRER WHEN YOU
FILE A DIMMER- IF THERE'S AN
ANALYSIS IN THE COMPUTER SAYS
ARE THE HELP WITH SAYS LOOK AT
YOU KNOW YOU FORGOTTEN ELEMENT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
DEMURRER IT IS GRANTED IT
SIMPLY MEANS THAT THAT THE
BENCH OFFICER THEN IS BLURTED
THAT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S A AN
ELEMENT THAT'S BEEN OMITTED AND
THUS FOCUS THE ATTENTION OF THE
CLERK OF THE COURT SO. ANYWAY
I'M SURE I'LL BE BACK WITH
OTHER APPLICATIONS AS THIS
INVOLVES ONE OF THANK JUDGE DOC
OR THE FINEST PRESIDING IN THE
HISTORY ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT WOULD SAY THAT EVEN IF I
WON A PRESS ATTORNEY IN ORDER.
COUNTY SO. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION VERSION I
VOTE. RIGHT THERE'S A MOTION OF
BY SENATOR STERN AND THE MOTION
IS. DO PASS. TO SENATOR PROPS
OF TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ALRIGHT A MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
JACKSON HI JACKSON I BORDERS
WERE JUST I WOULD ALSO
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I'D JONES.
JONES I AM MONNING MONNING AYE
STERN STERN I AM BURKE HI I'M
BURKE I Y. CASKEY BECAUSE HE I
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL MOVE
ON NOW TO- FILE ITEM FIVE. A
SENATOR LEYVA AND WE WILL
CONCLUDE WITH OUR MEMBERS. SB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE AFTER
PRESENTATION BY. SENATOR LEYVA
AGAIN TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH IN SUPPORT OTHERS SAID
THEN IN SUPPORT TO THE
MICROPHONE TO LIST YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION THEN WILL
INVITE THE OPPOSITION APPEARED
TWO MINUTES TWO PEOPLE EACH ERA
AND THEN OPPOSITION TO EXTEND
NAME AND AFFILIATION FROM THE
MICROPHONE SO. WITH THAT GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR LABOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
TODAY S. R. SIXTY SIX
COMMEMORATES THE FORTY SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF ROE V. WADE BY
RECOGNIZING THAT WOMEN HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
THE REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS AS
WELL AS ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE ROE V. WADE
DECISION MADE ACCESS TO
ABORTION BOWL SAFE AND LEGAL
AND IS GREATLY IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF WOMEN AND FAMILIES
THIS LANDMARK DECISION REMAINS
A CORNERSTONE OF WHAT EFFORTS
TOWARDS EQUALITY. THIS DECISION
PROVIDED CRITICAL REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM THAT HAS ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN SOCIETY
INCLUDING POLITICALLY SOCIALLY
AND ECONOMICALLY CALIFORNIA HAS
LED THE COUNTRY AND SUPPORTING
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND MUST
CONTINUE IN THIS CRITICAL ROLE.
THE CAL IS THE CORPORATE NUYS A
ONE EIGHT THE WOMAN TURNED TO
SEE PROTECT HER CONCERT IN ALL
RIGHT TO SEE FOR YEARS. ROE V.
WADE WAS DEAD. TURNING PRO V.
BUT ONCE AGAIN THE BOARD AND-
HEALTH CRISIS 7% OF AMERICANS
OPPOSE EFFORTS TO DO SO SAID
ANOTHER WAY 70% OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE SIMPLY PUT OVERTURNING
ROE V. WADE BUT NOT INTO
PORTION WOULD SIMPLY MEAN THAT
WOMEN WOULD HAVE UNSAFE
ABORTIONS AND DIE. HERE WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS MOLLY
ROBESON FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND SHEENA HOVIS NERVE. NARAL
NATE NAY BRAWL SORRY AS FOR THE
RUN ALRIGHT LADIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TWO MINUTES PLEASE
YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHANNON HOW
THIS TIME THE DIRECTOR FOR
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA.
NAY ROW IS THE OLDEST AND
LARGEST ABORTION RIGHTS
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN THE
COUNTRY WITH TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION MEMBERS NATIONALLY AND
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FORTY SEVEN YEARS
AGO READ THE WAY TO GIVE WOMEN
THE ABILITY TO CONTROL THEIR
OWN REPRODUCTIVE DESTINIES. A
RIGHT THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO
WOMEN BEING EQUAL. IN SOCIETY.
THE ANNIVERSARY OF ROE SHOULD
BE A CELEBRATION FOR THE
PROGRESS OF OUR COUNTRY. AND
YET THE FORTY SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY A SOMBER. THIS
LANDMARK SUPREME COURT DECISION
IS ON THE LINE LIKE NEVER
BEFORE. IN MARCH THE COURT WILL
HEAR ARGUMENTS IN JUNE MEDICAL
SERVICES VERSE KEY. THE FIRST
MAJOR CHALLENGE TO ABORTION
ACCESS AND SPREAD KAVANAUGH'S
CONFIRMATION. THE CASE WHICH
CONCERNS A LAW IDENTICAL TO A
TEXAS LAW THAT THE SUPREME
COURT STRUCK DOWN JUST FOUR
YEARS AGO. IT'S FURTHER PROOF
THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS PAID BACK
HIS DEBTS TO THE ANTI CHOICE
EXTREMISTS. WHO PUT HIM IN
OFFICE. SINCE KAVANAUGH'S
CONFIRMATION AN EMBOLDENED ANTI
CHOICE MOVEMENT HAS UNLEASHED
AN UNPRECEDENTED WAVE OF
ABORTION BANS WITH THE SPECIFIC
INTENT. OF GETTING A CASE TO
THE SUPREME COURT AND ROE.
EARLIER THIS MONTH TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVEN ANTI CHOICE LAWMAKERS
IN CONGRESS SIGNED ONTO AN
AMICUS BRIEF URGING THE COURT
TO RECONSIDER ROE. IT IS NO
SURPRISE THE JUST FIFTEEN OF
THESE CONGRESS MEMBERS ARE
WOMEN. WE MAY NOT KNOW WHAT THE
FUTURE HOLDS FOR ROW. BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT SUPPORT FOR THE RIGHT
TO ACCESSIBLE XIN IS MORE
POPULAR THAN EVER. LIKE SUPPORT
FOR ROE V. WADE IS AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH. 77% OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION THAT'S NOT JUST
MAJORITY AT THE CONSENSUS. IN
OUR NATION'S HISTORY. ROW IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF WHO WE ARE
AS A COUNTRY UNDERSCORING THE
BASIC PRINCIPLE THAT WOMEN
CANNOT BE EQUAL PARTNERS IN
SOCIETY WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO
MAKE PERSONAL DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR OWN BODIES AND FUTURES.
ON BEHALF OF NARAL I THANK
CENTER LEYVA LEYVA FOR BRING
FOR THIS RESOLUTION I'M
GRATEFUL TO CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE FOR FIGHTING TO
PROTECT AND EXPAND REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM. AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT RESOLUTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
KEREN MEMBERS AYE MOLLY ROPES
AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THE
SEVEN AFFILIATES WHO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE FOR OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS.
THEIR HUNDRED NAY HEALTH
CENTERS IN THE STATE. I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR LEYVA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP OFFERING THIS
RESOLUTION TO CELEBRATE THE
FORTY SEVENT ANNIVERSARY OF
THE HISTORIC. ROE V. WADE
SUPREME COURT DECISION. WHILE
WE CELEBRATE THIS ANNIVERSARY
WE ALSO MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE RIGHT TO SAFE LEGAL
ABORTION IS UNDER ATTACK AS
SHANNON IS MENTIONED. LAST YEAR
OVER THREE HUNDRED ABORTION
RESTRICTIONS BY EXTREMIST
POLITICIANS WERE INTRODUCED.
ALL AIMED A LIMITING ACCESS AND
STRIPPING AWAY FREEDOM FROM
PREGNANT PEOPLE AND ASHANTI
MENTION THIS YEAR THE SUPREME
COURT WILL HEAR A DECISION THAT
COULD UNDO THE PROTECTIONS
GRANTED BY ROE V. WADE. WE ARE
FORTUNATE IN CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
LEADERS WHO STAND WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND UNDERSTAND THAT
ABORTION CARE IS HEALTH CARE
AND HEALTH CARE IS A HUMAN
RIGHT. WE ALSO THINK THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE FOR
CONTINUING TO TAKE STEPS TO
EXPAND NOT BANNED AND INVEST IN
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. INCLUDING SAFE LEGAL
ABORTION. WE ALSO THANK YOU ALL
FOR BRINGING AWARENESS THROUGH
THIS RESOLUTION AND FOR THESE
REASONS ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT AS
OUR SIXTY SIX. ENERGIZED VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
IF TWO MINUTES EACH. SURE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GREG BIRCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL I'M SURE YOU REALIZE
WITH THE RECENT CHANGES ON THE
SUPREME COURT THAT ROE VERSUS
WADE DECISION IS ON LIFE
SUPPORT. BUT I ALSO BELIEVE
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR ABORTION IS
IN A PRECARIOUS SITUATION
BECAUSE THE MORAL REASONING
USED TO JUSTIFY ABORTION IS
BEING EXPOSED ABORTION IS ONLY
SURVIVED THIS LONG BECAUSE
PROPONENTS WERE ABLE TO DECEIVE
PEOPLE ABOUT THE BRUTAL REALITY
OF THE PRACTICE. JUST LISTEN TO
THE WAY THE BOARD IT'S
ADVOCATES TALK ABOUT THE
PROCEDURE. DO YOU HEAR THE
LANGUAGE GYMNASTICS USED TO
DISTRACT PEOPLE AWAY FROM
THINKING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
DURING AN ABORTION. WHY DO THEY
DO THAT. WHY CAN'T THEY TALK
ABOUT ABORTION IN PLAIN AN
EXACTING LANGUAGE I THINK YOU
KNOW THE ANSWER. IT DISTRACTING
PEOPLE FROM THE REALITY OF WAR
XIN HAS BECOME NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE WITH ADVANCES IN
ULTRASOUND TECHNOLOGY. I HAVE
THREE KIDS OF MY OWN AND I
REMEMBER BEING IN FIRST
INTRODUCED TO MY CHILDREN
THROUGH THE ULTRASOUND MACHINE.
I SAW MY DAUGHTER'S HEART
BEATING IN MY SON'S ARMS AND
LEGS IN MOTION JUST A FEW
MONTHS AFTER CONCEPTION. IT WAS
AN UNBELIEVABLE EXPERIENCE FOR
A NEW FATHER. SO WHEN I THINK
ABOUT WHAT ABORTION IS I RECALL
THOSE FLICKERING ULTRASOUND
PICTURES AND I THINK OF UNBORN
CHILDREN JUST LIKE MY OWN
GETTING THEIR LITTLE LIMBS TORN
OFF BY AN ABORTIONIST. THE
HORROR OF IT CAN HARDLY BE
EXPRESSED AND I THINK HOW CAN
AN INTELLIGENT IN OTHERWISE
VERY NICE AND GOOD HEARTED
PEOPLE JUST. MY TRUTH REVEALING
EXPERIENCE WITH AN ULTRASOUND
MACHINE IS REPEATED THOUSANDS
OF TIMES A DAY. AND THIS TRUTH
TELLING TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING
HEARTS AND MINDS AND CONVINCING
MANY MANY HARDENED. PRO
ABORTION ADVOCATES THAT NOTHING
JUSTIFIES THIS BARBARIC
PRACTICE. I'M HERE TODAY TO
REMIND YOU OF THE CRUEL REALITY
YOU ARE CELEBRATING IN HOPES
THAT ONE DAY GOD WILL OPEN YOUR
EYES IN TURN YOU INTO PRO LIFE
ADVOCATES AS HE IS DONE WITH
MILLIONS OF OTHERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU PROTEST
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ONE THAT SELLS AND I SERVICE
THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR LIFE RECENTLY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ANNOUNCED THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL BECOME A NO
KILL STATE. WHEN IT COMES TO SO
CALLED UNWANTED DOGS AND CATS
YET HERE TODAY YOU'RE VOTING ON
A RESOLUTION TO CELEBRATE THE
INTENTIONAL KILLING OF SIXTY
MILLION HUMAN BEINGS. AND
HURTING THEIR MOTHERS FOR A
LIFETIME BUT THE IRONY OF THAT
JUXTAPOSITION SINK IN FOR A
MOMENT. ALSO THE WOMAN AT THE
CENTER OF THE ROAD BE WEIGHED
FISSION CHAIN ROW IS ACTUALLY A
REAL PERSON BY THE NAME OF
NORMA MCCORVEY. SHE WROTE A
BOOK ONE BY LOVE THAT DESCRIBES
HOW SHE WAS MISTREATED IN USED
BY THE ABORTION ACTIVISTS.
LATER SHE HAD A CONVERSION A
BECAME A PRO LIFE LEADER. YOU
SEEN OUR- NORMAL COOPER CORBIS
OWN WORDS THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID
AND I QUOTE. YOU ARE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT AFTER YOU HAD AN
ABORTION ABORTION KINDA SUCKS
YOUR SOUL DRY. IT MAKE SURE
VERY ANGRY PERSON INSIDE FROM
WHAT I HAVE SEEN IN QUOTE AND
SHE SAW A LOT OF ABORTIONS
THAT'S NOT AN ABORTION CLINIC
MANAGER SIMILE DOCTOR BERNARD
NATHANSON THE FOUNDER OF NAY
RAW AND A FORMER ABORTIONIST
REFERRED TO ABORTION AS QUOTE.
THE MOST ATROCIOUS HOLOCAUST IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNITED
STATES. KILLING THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US THE WEEK
THE VOICELESS THE QUOTE IN
PERFECT. AND THE QUOTE AND
WANTED IS A LEAD FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS THAT AFFECTS
ALL OF THIS. BABY GIRLS ARE
BEING KILLED JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE FEMALE IS THAT
SOMETHING WE CELEBRATE. 90% OF
BABIES IDENTIFIED AS HAVING
DOWN SYNDROME WERE KILLED HERE
IN OUR COUNTRY WELL IN SOME
OTHER COUNTRIES. DOWN SYNDROME
HAS BECOME EXTINCT AS- HUMAN
BEINGS WITHOUT DIAGNOSIS ARE
LEGALLY KILLED THROUGH ABORTION.
BABIES AND BABIES OF COLOR
BEING KILLED BY ABORTION AT
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES. WE DO
NOT SOLVE POVERTY BY KILLING
POOR CHILDREN. WE HAVE A DREAM
WHEN WOMEN CAN SUCCEED WITHOUT
HAVING TO KILL OUR CHILDREN WE
HAVE A DREAM WHERE WE CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
WOMEN HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT WE NEED WHEN FACING THE
CHALLENGES OF AN UNEXPECTED
PREGNANCY THE AQ SO THAT SOME
DAY AS ABORTION BECOMES
UNTHINKABLE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THE YOU WAY OVER THE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS. I
NOTED THIS. RECOGNITION OF A
FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOM FOR WOMEN
CORD FORTY SEVEN YEARS AGO. AND
I LOOK AROUND THIS ROOM AND
REALIZED THAT MANY OF THE
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM WERE NOT A
LIFE. BEFORE ROE. AND SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT LIFE WAS
LIKE BEFORE ROE V. WADE. I WAS
TWENTY THREE SO NOW YOU'LL KNOW
HOW WILL DIE I'M ABOUT TO BE. A
WIN ROLE. WAS ACKNOWLEDGED BY
THE US SUPREME COURT. AND I HAD
A NUMBER OF FRIENDS WHO I HAD
TO THE UNEXPECTED UNWANTED
PREGNANCIES WHO WANTED TO
TERMINATE THOSE PREGNANCIES
THEY WERE IN SCHOOL THEY WANTED
TO CONTINUE GETTING THEIR
EDUCATION THERE WERE NO
RESOURCES FOR WOMEN WHO BECAME
PREGNANT. AT THAT POINT IN TIME
MANY YOUNGER WOMEN HAD TO LEAVE
SCHOOL AND ENDED UP IN LIVES TO
POVERTY WERE LIVES TO SHANE.
AND SO ROE V. WADE GAVE WOMEN
AN OPPORTUNITY NOT TRUST TO
MAKE THEIR OWN. PERSONAL
CHOICES ABOUT MOTHERHOOD AND
PARENTHOOD BUT ALSO THE CHOICE
OF LIFE BECAUSE SO MANY WOMEN
WHO WERE DESPERATE TO END AN
UNWANTED PREGNANCY WOULD END UP
WITH SEPSIS AND DIE. THERE WERE
WINGS OF HOSPITALS EXCLUSIVELY
FOR WOMEN WHO HAD TRIED TO SELF
INDUCE AN ABORTION OR HAD A
BOTCHED ABORTION DOWN IN MEXICO
OR BY SOMEONE WHO WAS NOT
QUALIFIED TO PERFORM THIS
PROCEDURE WE WERE LOSING
MOTHERS WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
MOTHERS WHO HAD SIX SEVEN EIGHT
NINE CHILDREN WHO COULD NOT
AFFORD TO FEED THEIR CHILDREN
LEAVE THEM AS WAR FRIENDS
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO DESPERATE
TO END UP PREGNANT. SO I JUST
WANT TO REMIND THOSE OF YOU IN
THIS ROOM WHO WERE NOT HERE
THEN. THIS WAS A REAL PROBLEM
ABORTION WILL NOT END. WOMEN
WANT AND I BELIEVE DIFFERENTLY
THAN YOU BUT WITH RESPECT THAT
THIS IS A WOMAN'S CHOICE. AND
IT IS ONE THAT SHE IS ENTITLED
TO MAKE WITH HER DOCTOR WITH
HER FAMILY WITH HER GOD WITH
WHOM EVER SHE CHOOSES IT IS NOT
MY RIGHT IT IS NOT YOUR RIGHT
IT IS THE RIGHT OF EVERY WOMAN.
AND SO WE ARE HERE NOW FORTY
SEVEN YEARS LATER WITH ROLE AT
GREAT RISK BECAUSE IT HAS
BECOME A POLITICAL FOOTBALL IT
HAS BECOME A DIVERSION IN THE
POLITICAL WORLD WHICH IS OF
GREAT SADNESS TO ME THAT WOMEN
ARE YET AGAIN THE PINATA OF
POLITICS. AND I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND SO I
AM VERY PROUD I HAVE CARRIED
THIS BILL PREVIOUSLY I AM PROUD
TO BE A CO AUTHOR I THINK WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER WHO WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT. AND WE USED TO
HAVE A SAYING THAT LIFE BEGINS
AT CONCEPTION AND ENDS AT BIRTH
BECAUSE THE VERY SAME PEOPLE OR
I SHOULD SAY MANY OF THOSE SAME
PEOPLE WHO SAY- BUT THIS IS
LIFE. ONCE THAT LIFE OCCURS
THEY ARE UNWILLING TO HELP
THOSE WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO FEED
OR CLOTHE OR HOUSE THOSE
CHILDREN THEY IGNORE THEM. THEY
SAY THAT IS YOUR PROBLEM THAT
IS YOUR DESTINY THAT IS YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND SO UNLESS
AND UNTIL WE HAVE A CONSISTENT
POSITION ONE THAT ALSO TALKS
ABOUT THE ABILITY TO MAKE. A
CONTRACEPTION AVAILABLE BECAUSE
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR IS ONE OF GOD'S
WAYS TO PROCREATE THE SPECIES
AT WHETHER IT'S DONE. IN
MARRIAGE WHETHER IT'S DONE
THROUGH A VIOLENT ACT. WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT MEN HAVE THE
LADY COME A DECISION ABOUT WHEN
WEATHER IN WITH. THEY CHOOSE TO
HAVE THAT MOST PRECIOUS FAMILY
WITH THAT. I WOULD THE OPEN THE
FLOOR WE'LL START WITH SENATOR
MINING AND THEN OUR OR CENTER
CONSOLE AS YOU WERE FIRST
PLEASE. EVERYTHING I WANTED TO
SAY BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD ESPECIALLY IN THIS
DAY AND AGE WHERE- WOMEN'S
RIGHTS ARE BEING ATTACKED AND
TO SEE AN AMICUS BRIEF WITH OUT
AMICUS BRIEF. WITH A MAJORITY
OF MEN MAIL LEGISLATORS MAKING
DECISIONS FOR WOMEN I FEEL AS
IS BEYOND UNFAIR SO I THINK IT
IS- INCH. AND I'M SO GLAD THAT
WE HAVE TO- YOU HAVE THIS AND
I'M GLAD WE'RE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION BUT IT SADDENED. OF
SADDENS ME AS WELL THAT THIS
DAY AND AGE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
RESOLUTIONS AND WHERE WE STAND
BUT- FOR THAT I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
SENATOR MONEY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF I MIGHT JUST A
QUESTION FOR THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD REPRESENTATIVE- I
THINK ALL OF YOU MADE REFERENCE
TO INCREASED LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS TO RESTRICT ACCESS- NOT
JUST TO ABORTIONS BUT IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN ACCESS TO FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES IS THAT
CORRECT ACROSS THE COUNTRY I.
AND DOESN'T THE DATA SHOW THAT
ACCESS TO FAMILY PLANNING CAN
ACTUALLY REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
ABORTIONS- BY REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF UNWANTED PREGNANCIES.
AND YOU KNOW CAN YOU GIVE US AN
ESTIMATE OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD SERVICES.
THAT ARE SUPPORTING WOMEN'S
HEALTH AND- FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES UNDER PERCENT OF OUR
SERVICES WOULD HELP WOMEN'S
HEALTH ALL PEOPLE'S HEALTH AND
REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES BUT SOME
OF THE LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS.
HAVE BOTH SIDES AND HAVE
SUCCEEDED IN DENYING GOVERNMENT
FUNDING TO ANY OF THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
AND WOULD IT BE SAFE TO
CONCLUDE BECAUSE OF THAT LOSS
OF SUPPORT- WOMEN WILL HAVE
FEWER OPTIONS AND- LIKELY
PURSUE. ON HEALTH FOR SOLUTIONS
IN OTHER STATES ABSOLUTELY YEAH
THANK YOU I'M AN OF THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED I'D BE HONORED TO
MOVE IT AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A PLACE FOR CO AUTHORS
IT WOULD BE HONORED TO HAVE A
HEAVY SENATOR MONNING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
ANY FURTHER. DISCUSSION SENATOR
STERN. APPRECIATE THE
HISTORICAL CONTEXT MADAM CHAIR
AND FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I'M AFTER WOMEN'S CAUCUS ONLY
BE NOW LIE HERE AND SIGN ON TO
IF I MAY UM. AND JUST. STATED.
AS MUCH AS WOMEN ARE BEING
CHALLENGED AND DEMONIZED RIGHT
NOW THAT- I'VE A FEELING THE
PUSH BACKS GONNA BE IMMENSE AND
NATIONWIDE IN EVERY POCKET OF
SOCIETY- THE PUSH BACK WILL BE
WILL BE HEARD BUT IT'S CRITICAL
THAT MALE ALLIES AND ESPECIALLY
THIS NEXT GENERATION STEP UP
AND SAY YOU KNOW I PERSONALLY.
I BENEFITTED FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD SERVICES MYSELF AND
I'VE BEEN THROUGH TOUGH FAMILY
PLANNING CHOICES. GROWING UP
THROUGH YOU KNOW MY THREE YEAR
THREE AND A HALF DECADES AROUND
HERE. THESE ARE HARD THESE ARE
HARD MOMENTS IN LIFE BUT THE
LAST THING WE NEED IS
GOVERNMENT COMING IN AND-
INSERTING ITSELF INTO WHAT'S A
VERY INTIMATE AND IMPORTANT
HEALTH DECISIONS SO I JUST
APPRECIATE YOU CONTINUOUSLY
BANGING HIS DRUM HOPEFULLY
CALIFORNIA BEHAVING BUT I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE TO BE YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY THIS DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE THE PLACE THAT. WOMEN CAN
FEEL SAFE BUT- THANK YOU. RIGHT
WITH THAT NO FURTHER COMMENTS-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER
LEYVA THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR OF
THANK YOU MEMBERS. YOU KNOW
WHAT FOR THREE YEARS I CARRIED
A BILL TO OFFER MEDICATED
ABORTION ON UC AND CSU CAMPUSES
SO FOR THREE YEARS I HAVE HEARD
THE OPPOSITION SHAME WOMEN. AND
DEMONIZED WOMEN WHO HAVE HAD
ABORTIONS. I'M NOT EVER ASKING
SOMEONE TO HAVE AN ABORTION YOU
DO NOT HAVE TO HAVE AN ABORTION
THE GENTLEMAN HERE DOES NOT
HAVE TO HAVE AN ABORTION. BUT
WOMEN SHOULD HAVE THAT CHOICE
WE DON'T KNOW ANYONE'S LIFE
HISTORY WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH BUT THAT
WOMEN SHOULD HAVE THAT RIGHT AS
I WAS CARRYING SB THREE TWENTY
IN SB TWENTY FOUR. THROUGH THE
PROCESS I BECAME MORE AND MORE
ADAMANT AND AGAIN BECAUSE OF
THE **** THAT I SAW WAS PUT ON
WOMEN AND I'M TIRED OF THAT I'M
TIRED OF WOMEN BEING SHAMED FOR
TRIPS IS AT. MAKING FOR
THEMSELVES THE FAMILY IT'S MY
RIGHT IT'S NOT YOUR RIGHT IS
THE RIGHT OF THE WOMAN WHO IS
MAKING THAT DECISION WITH HER
PHYSICIAN. WITH HER FAMILY SO I
AM HAPPY TO CARRY THIS I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE I WILL ALWAYS
BE PRO CHOICE AND WE GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WOMEN ARE NOT
SHAMED FOR MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR OWN BODY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION. WHICH
IS. THAT THE RESOLUTION BE
ADOPTED WE HAVE A MOTION BY. A
CENTER AND SALAS WAS. AND.
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND SENATOR
MONEY. WITH THE GROUP GAME IT'S
GOOD TO BUT ALSO HAVE A MALE.
WHO IS SUPPORTING THIS ISSUE AS
WELL FRANKLY SO WITH THAT THE
MOTION IS THAT THE RESOLUTION
BE ADOPTED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE BORCHERS.
TO RUSSELL GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I'D JONES. JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN AYE ON
BURKE. ARMORED AYE AYE CASKEY
CASKEY I'D. SEVEN SIX TO ONE
THAT THE MEASURE IS OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS THAT ARE LABOR
THANK YOU ALL. WE HAVE ONE
OTHER ITEM AND THAT IS SENATOR
STERN FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE
. MARTY THIS
IS A FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SENATOR
STERN IS THAT YOU WILL BE.
TAKING ALL OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE DETAILED IN
THE ANALYSIS APPRECIATE THAT-
AND THE IF YOU WOULD OF PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MAN TURN
THAT'S CORRECT APPRECIATE THE
GOOD WORK OF THE COMMITTEE- IN
TAILORING THIS BILL AND WORKING
ON THE OPT OUT PROVISION AS
WELL AS AN IMPORTANT
GABRIELLE'S AROUND PRIVACY-
THIS BILL ESTIMATES FROM- THE
CRISES WE'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH
THE STATE- NAMELY PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF- THAT WERE
ROLLING THROUGH SEVEN
CALIFORNIA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ALSO. OUT OF THE FALL AND
WINTER BUT THIS GOES FOR
WILDFIRES FRANKLY FOR DISASTERS
OF ANY KIND WE FOUND MAJOR GAPS
ESSENTIALLY IS THE CHIP WELL
THOSE UP IN IN OUR MOTOR
MERGING NOTIFICATION PROPHECIES
IN THIS THOSE WHO ARE MAYBE NOT
AS TECH SAVVY AND ARE NOT
SIGNING UP FOR THAT TEXT ALERT-
USED GRANDMOTHER IT. EXAM THIS
CASE SO THAT SHE DOESN'T HAVE
ACCESS OR FUNCTIONAL NEEDS SHE
ACTUALLY IF YOU COULD I IT I
CAN'T GET HER TO USE THE IPHONE
A SENSE SIGN UP FOR THE TEXT
ALERTS BUT- BUT IN HER CASE SHE
ACTUALLY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
THERE'S A LARGE SWATH OF
CALIFORNIA TO AREN'T EVEN ABLE
TO ACCESS- NOTIFICATIONS FOR
WHEN DISASTERS HIT. GET
RESPONSE SO THIS TRYING TO RIP
THE THAT BY. ESSENTIALLY
STREAMLINING THE DATA SHARING
PROCESS- BETWEEN- OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PROVIDERS AND THE
COUNTY- THE COUNTY DATA THAT
HAS OF MORE PURVIEW FRANKLY
INTO WHERE THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ARE WHO ARE THOSE
WHO ARE ON AYE HSS. WHO HAVE
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
WE'RE PROBABLY MOST LIKELY BE
LEFT BEHIND INVENTIVE IS IT
DISASTER OR NOT SIGNED UP IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT THIS FRAMEWORK- PUTS
TOGETHER A WAY TO SAVE DOLLARS
AND FRANKLY. NOT HAVE A
SCRAMBLING EVERY TIME THE GRID
SHUTS DOWN OR FIRE HITS US THE
WERE ALL OPERATING FROM ONE AND
UNIFIED DATA FRAMEWORK AND WE
CAN. FINALLY GET THOSE PEOPLE
SAFE BECAUSE PEOPLE'S LIGHTS
WENT OFF THEIR BREEDERS WENT
OFF THEIR OXYGEN MACHINES WENT
DOWN WITH ZERO NOTICE
WHATSOEVER AND IN MY FAMILY'S
CASE WE BILL MY GRANDMOTHER OUT
WE FOUND OUT PARKER'S GOING
DOWN AND WHEN FOUNDER NOT
EVERYONE IS THAT LUCKY SO
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL. STARTS TO
REMEDY SOME OF THAT IN A SMALL
WAY- WE HAVE- JEAN HEARST- HAVE
VENTURA COUNTY I KNOW I THINK
RC RC. A IS ALSO HERE SO-
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS ON
THE GROUND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON. NICE
TO SEE YOU AS WELL CARE HAPPY
NEW YEAR I JEAN HEARST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS INS
IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR STERN.
SEVEN THE THREE. ACTION ISSUE I
CAME TO LIGHT IN THE COUNTY OF
INTER AFTER THE VERY
DEVASTATING THOMAS FIRE- WHERE
EVACUATION TEND TO BE VERY
QUICK IS THE FIRST TIME BUYER-
PERSONNEL AND ENGINES WERE
ACTUALLY DEPLOYED TO EVACUATE-
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY COUNTY LIE IS THAT IF
THEY HAD ONLY HAD ADDITIONAL
CONTACT I KEEP THE THIRTY. FOUR
I'M EXISTING CLIENTS THAT WE
CURRENTLY SIR AND ARE SO.
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS I IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE IF WE COULD HAVE
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
FIRST FIRST FIRST I'M SENATOR
JACKSON. OF KNOWS THAT WE'VE
ATTEMPTED TO REMEDY- THIS ISSUE
BUT IT CERTAINLY HAS COME TO-
MORE URGENCY IN TERMS OF THE
INITIATION OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF THAT OCCURRED
THIS FALL- COUNTY FEELS. THAT
IT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CARE
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS AND- WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
TO REACH THEM IN AN EMERGENCY.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I'VE- THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHN KENNEDY ON
BEHALF OF RC RC REPRESENTING
THE STATE'S THIRTY SEVEN RURAL
COUNTIES- WE'VE BORN A- IF
YOU'RE A LARGE PORTION OF THE
P. S. P. S. EVENTS. AND WERE
PRIORITIZING NOTIFICATIONS AND
MITIGATION OF THE IMPACTS TO A
IF AND POPULATIONS SO WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL-
AS IS CURRENTLY IN PRINT. OF
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT HERE-
TAPPING SAID REVIEWING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE WORK FROM
AN IMPLEMENTATION PERSPECTIVE
BUT ONE OF FLAG A COUPLE THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE RESOLVED SO
THAT WE AVOID UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. UP THE FIRST
BEING THE OPT OUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE DESIRE FOR AN OPT OUT
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
FROM OUR LOCAL IT DIRECTORS-
WHETHER THAT WILL BE A
CHALLENGE WHETHER THEY'RE OPT
OUT PROVISIONS IN PLACE NOW OR
IF THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO CREATE
THOSE CAPABILITIES- BECAUSE WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
REACH OUT TO THESE INDIVIDUALS.
IN THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY SO
REPORTER FINDING LANGUAGE ON
THAT. AND THEN THE SECOND
AMENDMENT THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED.
WHICH WOULD CABIN THE THIS-
COMMUNICATION CAPABILITY ON-
SITUATIONS IN WHICH THERE NEEDS
TO BE AN EVACUATION WE THINK
THAT'S WHOLLY APPROPRIATE FOR A
LARGE MAJORITY OF THE OTHER
TYPES OF EMERGENCIES HERE. IT'S
NOT REALLY WELL SUITED FOR PS
PS EVENTS BECAUSE THE GENERAL
POPULATION DOESN'T NEED TO BE
EVACUATED BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS. SENSITIVE
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THAT
POPULATION THAT MIGHT SO
FINDING A WAY TO FACILITATE
COMMUNICATIONS TO IT WAS A FUN
POPULATIONS. FOR THE LIMITED
PURPOSES OF NOTIFICATION AND
SEEING IF PEOPLE NEED
ASSISTANCE SO WITH THAT YOU
KNOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
AUTHOR- AND ALSO EXPLORING WAYS
TO ENSURE THAT UTILITIES CAN
HAVE SOME TYPE OF ACCESS TO
THIS INFORMATION. BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING
NOTIFICATIONS AND D. S. P. S.
OFFENSE AND SO AS LONG AS IT'S
NARROWLY TAILORED. AND LIMITED
TO NOTIFICATION AND PROTECTION
OF ASSISTANCE WITH THERE'S A
WILL THERE'S ALSO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
PRECIADO COMMITTEE TAKEN THE.
SUB TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY THE WITNESS DOESN'T
SUPPORT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SING
UP WILL BRING TO THE DYESS
MISTER VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU
CHAIR OF TWICE A ONE DAY CENTER
STERN I'M VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR. YOUR EFFORTS. SINGER I'M
NOT SURE WHO IT IS YEAH BUT.
QUICK QUESTION DO WE HAVE IT.
THE DEFINITION. OR CATEGORIES
OF ELDERLY IS THERE AN AGE
RANGE IS OVER SIXTY FIVE WHAT
IS IT THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION
AND YEAH BECAUSE I THINK HE'S
REFERRING TO IN THE PROVISION
OF THE WELFARE INSTITUTION
BECAUSE THEY WERE TOUCHING.%
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT POSSIBLE
EVACUATIONS IN AREAS IN WHICH
ELDERLY OR DISABLED CLIENTS
RESERVE. I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
TO FIND ELSEWHERE IN THE CODE I
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
ONE HE USES A HOUSEKEEPING ITEM
IF MAYBE THERE MIGHT BE. SOME
SORT OF REFERENCE THAT CAN BE
CREATED THAT IDENTIFIES
DISABLED- AND IN AGE RANGE YEAH
DO YOU MIND ALSO FIVE WAIT
MAYBE EIGHTY A MAYBE THAT'S IT.
AND TERRIBLY FROM THE COUNTY'S
PERSPECTIVE THESE ARE GONNA BE
FOLKS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
SERVICES SO THEY HAVE TO BE-
BOTH INCOME AND AGE AND
CONDITION ELIGIBLE OKAY LAST
QUESTION IS. RC RC ROB POINT ON
OUT. EMERGENCY PERSONNEL. FOR
IT CORRECT ME IF I'M MISTAKEN.
THEY ARE NOT IN A POSITION OF
NOT GOING TO SOMEONE'S HOME TO
HELP EVACUATE IF THEY OPT OUT
IT'S ALMOST AS IF WE COULD BE.
ARE ABUSING AND WASTING
RESOURCES WITH THE NOTION THAT
SOMEONE CAN OPT OUT. UNDER
THESE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES IF
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL WOULD GO
ANYWAYS. IT'S A FAIR POINT L.
BUT ANYWAY JUST SOME OF YOU TO
CONSIDER YEAH IT'S A GOOD IDEA
MAYBE VENTURA COUNTY JUST WENT
THROUGH THIS A FEW TIMES CAN
WEIGH IN BECAUSE I I'M
SENSITIVE TO. WELL MISTER
KENNEDY REYES THERE TOO AND YOU
DON'T TO ADD YOUR RESPECT TO
SEE. RIGHT THAT'S DIVIDE AT THE
SAME TIME. IF THE MECHANICS
DON'T WORK AND YOUR- THEY'RE
ALREADY GOING YOUR HOUSE
ANYWAYS AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
JUST FIND IT THROUGH SOME OTHER
WAY DO YOU ADD ANOTHER. IN THIS
IS THIS ISN'T ABOUT NOT GOING
TO YOUR HOME THIS IS. THE
ABILITY TO OPT OUT OF
DISCLOSING THE INFORMATION. SO
IN OTHER WORDS YOU'RE PEOPLE
WHO DON'T WANT TO BE BOTHERED
BY GOVERNMENT I KNOW BUT IF FOR
EXAMPLE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
CANNOT SEND A MESSAGE THAT
INDIVIDUAL ARE THEY NOT DâN
OBLIGATED TO. TO GUARANTEE THE
THAT SOMEONE IS EVACUATED
THROUGH THE GOING DOOR TO DOOR.
I UNDERSTAND. THAT'S WHAT YOU
JUST SO MANY CONSIDERED NO BIG
DEAL BUT JUST AMERICAN WHETHER
IT'S A BIG DEAL TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE WANT TO PROVIDE
SERVICES SO IN RESPONSE TO THE
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT AYE HSS
THEY'VE ALREADY GOT A QUALIFY-
UNDER THIS BILL AND THE OTHER
THE OTHER THING AND THIS IS
MODELED AFTER BILL THAT I'M
HOPING YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH
ME ON SEVEN NINETY FOUR WHICH
IS A RE INTRODUCTION OF A BILL
THAT I. DID LAST YEAR
ADDRESSING MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THE INFORMATION SO
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE EVERYBODY
BE NOTIFIED WHEN THERE IS AN
EMERGENCY OR WHEN THERE'S A P.
AT NOW WITH THERE'S A PS PS-
AND BASICALLY INCLUDING
EVERYONE UNLESS THEY DON'T WANT
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
INFORMATION GIVING THEM THE
RIGHT TO OPT OUT SO THAT THEIR
INFORMATION WILL NOT BE IN THE
DATABASE THE GOES OUT TO PEOPLE
OUR HOPE OF COURSE IS THAT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE NOTIFIED
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME PEOPLE THAT
WOULD RATHER NOT. AND WHAT THE
OPT OUT PROVISION IS TO RESPECT
THE RIGHT OF PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
WANT TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE WON'T TRY
TO HELP THEM DURING AN
EMERGENCY JUST MEANS THEY HAVE
CHOSEN NOT TO BE PART OF THE
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE THESE EXTRA NEEDS AND HAVE
OUR AYE HSS ELIGIBLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRST RESPONDERS
HAVE MADE IT CLEAR TO US THEY
REALLY WANT TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THOSE PEOPLE FIRST BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE PEOPLE WHO NEED THE
HELP MOST AND I THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS. A TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IN AGAIN I AM
LOOKING TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS CONCEPT IT IN IN THE I
THINK IT'S SEVEN NINETY FOUR
WHICH IS A BILL I RE INTRODUCED
OF THAT DEALS WITH ITS FIRST
VACATION AS WELL CRITICALLY.
IMPORTANT EVENT CHAIR I. YOU
RAISE THE RIGHT. HOW TO. HOW
TO. WE'RE NOT GONNA GET IN THE
WAY DELIVERY THESE EMERGENCY
SERVICES. BUT I TO FIND. A
NIMBLE AND NOT CLUNKY WILL BE
TO GIVE THAT OPT OUT. POINT SO
IS IT UPON ENROLLMENT IF YOU
KNOW THEIR ANNUAL ENROLLMENT
PROCESS ALREADY HAPPENING CHAD
NEED TO ADD A BOX TO LIKE WHERE
THOSE MECHANICS ADDING WE WANT
TO WORK WITH COMMITTEE AND YOU
ON- TO MAKE THAT WORK BUT I
WOULD ALSO REYES. THIS BILL IS
LIMITED RIGHT NOW TO.
NOTIFICATIONS ABOUT EVACUATIONS
AND SO THE OTHER POINT THAT I
THINK IS AYE AYE TAKE WELL FROM
RC RC IS THAT. THE AID AND
ASSISTANCE PART TWO MAY BE AN
ISSUE SO IF THEY'RE NOT JUST
EVACUATING YOU SAY FROM LIKE IN
A P. S. P. S. INCIDENT THEY MAY
NOT EXACTLY WHAT YOU. WRITE IT
MAY NOT BE AN EVACUATION
NOTIFICATION BUT IT MAY BE A
NOTIFICATION LIKE YOUR POWERS
ABOUT TO GO OFF AND YOU'VE GOT
TO MAKE SURE YOU GOT A
GENERATOR ON SITE. SO AS THE AS
IF THE BILL MOVES FOR WE JUST.
I ONE OF. FLAG YOU MY OPEN THIS
TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH THAT
BECAUSE- THE- THE PEACE PS IS A
DIFFERENT ANIMAL I GUESS THAN
WE'VE SEEN. AS WAS THE GET OUT
OF YOUR HOUSE MAYBE IT'S HUNKER
DOWN AND STABLE WE GET WE GET
NOTICES WHEN THERE'S GONNA BE A
PS PS WE DON'T NECESSARILY GET
NOTICES WHEN AWHILE FIRES JUST
STARTED SO. SO THEY ARE THEY
ARE DIFFERENT BUT IF. YOU LOOK
AT SEVEN NINETY FOUR AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH RC RC ON THIS
I THINK WE CAN INCORPORATE THE
MALL IN THAT PROCESS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS SEEING NON A-
GROCERY RUN AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT
WITH THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
BORDERS. OR DECIDE TO RUSSELL
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D JONES.
JONES I AM MONNING. MONEY AYE
STERN. HE SAID THE- ALL RIGHT
IF WE COULD CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM THREE.
STERN STERN AYE WHY CASKEY
RECOUNTS THE AYE RIGHT THAT IS
EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
AND WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU
ALL